today me and the boys will be playing
among us with sapnap dream and george
three of the biggest minecraft youtubers
on the platform this video is an
emotional roller coaster and you want to
watch it i say we just jump right into
it
let's go
[Music]
it's me and mr beast this is actually
the first time i've ever been imposter
card swipes back
perfect all right there's gonna be a
dead body here i'm i'm gonna die i'm
gonna die so i'm not no i don't know
what to do i don't know what to do i've
never done this before i'm doing all my
tests okay the lights are fixed the
lights are fixed i'm calling jailer
hello let's hang out near each other so
we can be safe okay okay all right i
love you bye we need to be smart about
this i'm gonna go over here i don't know
who it could be i'm following sap
because i don't trust that landlubber
all right me and chandler are going to
hang out together because i'm sick of
getting killed every time i'm trying to
do a test oh no mr visa is going to kill
someone and get caught
he's going to kill someone and get
caught i guaran
yet doing this test chandler oh come
back come back trailer please don't
leave me taylor left me this game is so
nerve-wracking i have literally no
information right now but we have
cameras who's on the cameras carl
standing completely still
stop now it's something up they did it
right on the camera oh my god i can't
stop my bow yes george go record it i
put myself right in front of a camera
yes yo dead body right here all right so
we know who it is right because we were
all together all i know is it wasn't me
i was literally with a group of four
people the entire time i just didn't
want to die first round all i know is
that it's not chris it's not me it's not
mr beast and it's not chandler therefore
it's either sapnap or george george
caught it george watched it
wait i was in admin at the beginning and
then i went to
like the left side of the map where was
the body where was the body i have a
reasoning to believe it's someone here
sapnap satnap where were you this round
it started right and i went down okay i
went down and i went left towards
electrical i was trying to turn off the
light so someone was like turn off the
lights trying to turn off the lights oh
that's a wrap
that's not a wrap that's not a wrap
that's a simple like verbal mistake
simple rap who was in security i was in
security and would you like to know
something very interesting jeremy yeah
go ahead i may or may not have seen
someone kill someone on the cameras who
was it who did i see sat nap i saw you i
saw you sam nap
why wouldn't he say that earlier wait no
this is
i will tell you why he's literally
pulling this out of his butt george and
sap and then therefore it is also mr
beast
why would you say that earlier because
because i wanted to see if someone would
expose themselves if i didn't say
something oh that's you said that you're
gonna get earlier i trust that i'm
voting staff now he said there was a
game earlier today where he said he was
gonna do that
on george just watch out it's not me oh
my god i just completely exposed stop
now he's on to me oh boy this isn't good
for sure mr beast maybe not there's a
chance there's a chance it's not i'm
nervous i'm nervous i'm nervous okay i'm
booking it i'm getting out of here i
can't do anything to draw attention to
myself because i already have suspicion
he checked comms he checked comms get me
out of here get me out of here mr beast
no
leave me alone i don't know if he's
actually chasing me or not i'm scared of
mr beast now he might be trying to kill
me there's no way okay what do i do i
gotta kill someone oh my god he is
there's no way he's not he's doing this
on purpose he's been chasing me for
forever he's been chasing me for forever
he's been chasing me i'm just calling it
i'm just calling him
oh okay why were you chasing me jimmy
why are you chasing me you were chasing
me for like 20 minutes yeah because i'm
trying to stay with someone so i don't
get murdered what do you mean
no
no you were checking rooms and stuff are
you checking no i wasn't i literally was
following you i told you earlier i
played four games of this and every time
i get knocked out first look my point is
this mr beast has been killed first
because he's mad at the game he's still
alive how is he alive he has to be the
because i've been following people
around the thing you're getting mad at
me for doing right now dream kind of
sucks now not gonna lie i think it's
either mr beast or dream who else wants
me to follow them around follow me jimmy
i've lost my rights to follow dream
around i'll follow you chris you're my
buddy though okay so i don't want to go
with dream i think it could be dream or
mr beast honestly i think it could be
either dream is seeming a bit sus
i want to win off tasks baby
i'm dead i am dead
maybe that's nap or something closing
the door in order to get him to kill me
ah this is funny dude they're all so
suspicious of me there's no way there's
no way i win this that task is very
annoying where's george i want george
i'm doing all my electrical tests right
now so that way i don't die even though
i should be going to the meltdown is
someone gonna help me oh please don't go
off reactor oh no i'm dead i'm dead oh
i'm dead
don't do it don't kill me he's gonna
kill me
he's gonna kill me
no
run away run away run away run away oh
no chance no no
i
i knew it i actually knew it i knew it
what oh
my did we really
that's so that is so dumb yes yes we
would how did you guys not get there i
didn't know you couldn't call an
emergency meeting how did jimmy win
because you guys didn't fix the easiest
thing to fix on the face of the planet
oh my gosh
let's go
all right imposter baby let's do it oh
wait not muted
detective sapnap on the case i hope it
is a dream this round i need to let
somebody else do good i'm the master it
among us wait should i just kill him off
the bat i'm just gonna kill him
i guess he was afk i don't know no one's
noticed yet oh my gosh i don't know if
i'm gonna get away with this uh
interesting aha we tried to bait him in
the venting but it didn't work okay
lights are off the lights are out i
don't like this this is not good i'll
just go do my tasks i'll flick the
lights on oh they did it for me
carl
carl no no
don't kill me call is scary don't kill
me no need to know what the imposter's
do
that just happened right in front of you
thank you i'm pretty sure i just saw the
animation
why oh two people died and i know one of
the killers is cruz well i was just with
sapnab yeah i was about to say chris
just killed someone right in front of me
wait so did chris just kill sapnap just
in front of you yeah chris literally
just killed snap yes
avenge me avenge me oh okay perfect
because i saw chris van i guess we're
voting for chris yeah chris literally
just killed snap this isn't true wait
because i haven't said where the body is
yet and it wasn't saps it wasn't sapp's
body so where was george i don't know
why we're believing carl right now i i
don't remember where i was where was i
just listen it wasn't me i have a bad
memory where's the body carl cause i can
tell you who it was if you tell me where
the body was cafeteria okay well it's
not mr beast 100 it's not me and it's
not mr b's that's it all i know is vote
chris so it's not mr beast okay i
literally just watched chris murder snap
i watched it i watched chris vent to
murder him all right as i say if he
somehow weasels out of this i will kill
someone chris you're the worst
impossible i'm so tired i had to throw
chris under the bus for my own safety i
got this i don't know who it is i don't
know who to trust neither of them were
moving i'll sit with you guys let's go
to full call don't do this you don't
want to do this call we're just going to
play it cool not kill anyone just hang
out with the boys oh everyone's here the
whole squad's here oh no he's going to
come he's going to come he's going to
kill me don't do it
okay who do i trust who do i trust okay
just stay together let's all stay
together yeah yeah yeah let's all stay
together one big happy family no why why
are you leaving me they'll be a dead
body and they're going messing with like
that's not something george would do
like lights i feel like it's carl
carl
carl maybe it's not called this is too
much information i can't handle oneplus
it's a good stream carl's watching
oh who is that it's dream i don't like
being in a dream he said someone was in
here therefore someone was venting where
does the vent lead too slow i should
have gone with them i should have gone
with them and now somebody's gonna die
and i'm not gonna know who it is perfect
perfect carl call and dream okay protect
me whilst i do this protect me okay yeah
you saw that you saw that dream i know
you saw that
no
why'd you do this to me
why do you do this to me get out get out
get it go get up all disappeared it
didn't show in storage and then it
showed in storage stack no
second
exact number okay
he didn't go in he didn't go in he
didn't go in someone was venting in here
because it showed one person in admin
when no one was in admin i think i i
think this might be a wrap i'm gonna use
the button that was with mr b's first
time so i know it's not him he really
got away with that
he did that so good i think
i just saw george dead in security right
when he called this well you got unlucky
carl you got very unlucky i was with mr
b during the first round when there was
two kills that's the first thing and i
was actually going to expose you this
round but please for the love of god
don't throw right now dream i'll give
you uh you're you're exposed and it's
something you don't like it's that the
events show up on the admin card panel
jimmy please do not throw right now
dream
this is gonna go in dreams compilation i
swear to god let me give you reason one
reason one i was with mr beast during
the first round when there was a double
kill there cannot be two kills with this
long cooldown and we could have been
together that's that's reason one reason
two is me and mrs were just together
just now when he died two seconds ago
and you're the only one away this is
hilarious because it's actually me and
he's painting carl
reason three is that in the in that
round i was watching the admin card and
there was george was in cafeteria mr
beast was with me and there was one
other person in storage and there was no
one else walking in storage so guess
what someone was renting and it was you
everybody that's watching to acknowledge
the fact that i had nothing to do with
this throw that's all i want
back-to-back imposter dubs thank you
blown away
no there's nothing there's no way
what
how did that even happen i was with him
how did you not see the see my body
during i did not i i was with mr beast
like literally i must have left him for
two seconds to do reactor that was it
all i'm saying is next time i get
impostor let's try not to let me win